bonjour même si le bonjour le gars merci
beaucoup pour cette vidéo est donc moi
je procède directement avec la première
question par rapport à cette
intervention de deux grands
scientifiques pierre à pierre et main
son intervention en quelque sorte dans
l'écriture tu partages pas de nouvelles
informations
il ya une reprise d impression que tu as
dit avant donc c'est juste un moment de
blagues à aube il put donne pas mal de
temps quand même et qu'elle est en
rapport à l'amour en général et plus
précisément dans la médiation qu'elle
place il a dans ton écriture des vidéos
dans les visages je n'aime pas l'humour
je déteste ça non en fait le truc c'est
que je me pose pas spécialement la
question c'est juste que je suis
quelqu'un de d'éminemment drôle au
quotidien et j'aime bien faire des
blagues je me prend jamais au sérieux en
fait et du coup pour moi c'était à peu
près naturel de mettre ça dans les
vidéos même si ça n'a pas toujours été
comme ça au début je faisais un truc
très guindé et puis après j'ai des amis
qui m'ont dit mais pourquoi tu est
chiante comme ça dans tes vidéos alors
que tu l'aies pas dans la vraie vie et
du coup je me suis dit bon bah je vais
tenter de mettre un peu d'humour et puis
plus ça va plus apprécié est donc plus
jamais et hélas les dernières vidéos
c'est à les gérer
70% d'humour et 30% de science ok ça va
pas du tout et l avantage aussi
notamment pour pierre pierre c'est que
ça permet de faire des petites
respirations
parce que si on se prend un bloc de 10
15 minutes de savoir enfin un cours
magistral de 10 15 minutes dans la tête
au rythme du tube ça peut être un peu
difficile à gérer
et là justement d'avoir pierre pierre
qui nous parle pendant deux minutes ça
permet de faire une petite respiration
et j'aime bien voilà oui c'est ce que je
me suis dit mais je me disais en effet
calé par quoi tu commences est ce que tu
te dis ah oui comme ce serait bien de
respirer ou tu te dis en fait je
n'arrive pas à ne pas faire des blagues
etc c'est ma nature alors je fais comme
ça après je me dis ah oui alors c'est
bien parce que ça permet de respirer
ouais c'est un petit mélange des deux
mais au début c'était c'était un peu de
la sérendipité
effectivement c'était de la blague avant
et puis après je me suis rendu compte
que ça pouvait avoir un rôle
enfin une fonction intéressante par la
vidéo donc je me suis dit bon bah je
vais garder ça parce que c'est pas mal
ça fonctionne enfin j'ai eu des bons
retours dessus donc je me suis dit que
j'allais garder ça voilà ok donc
et est-ce qu'il ya d'autres changements
qui sont apparus depuis le début de ta
chère à part plus de moore est peut-être
moins des sciences en proportion au oui
bah avant la chaîne déjà le rôle le
faire la finalité de la chaîne a
complètement changé
à la base c'était plus je mettais en
ligne mais mes projets je pouvais faire
à la fac parce que j'ai fait un master
en journalisme scientifique pas mal
accès audio visuel donc on avait des
projets à rendre des trucs comme ça et
puis en parallèle comme nous prêter du
matériel on a pu enfin s'essayer à faire
des petites interviews des trucs comme
ça donc ça c'est un format un peu plus
pro je dirais ça me servaient de vitrine
professionnelle en fait et puis au fur
et à mesure bah plus j'ai eu faim plus
j'ai eu un job moi j'ai eu besoin de
m'en servir de vitrine et plus j'ai pu
vraiment expérimenté comme je voulais et
c'est là où j'ai commencé à faire un peu
n'importe quoi et se faire même si
beaucoup et par rapport plus à au
contexte précis de ta vidéo
moi j'ai jamais j'ai appris plein de
choses je connaissais pas du tout qu'il
ya cette échelle de la tomate minéraux
et ça ne la connaît puisque c'est pas
très intéressant on peut en tout cas
l'absence d assez rigolote et cause de
la langue mais mais il n'y a pas de
position de remplacement est est ce que
tu as une idée de profession de
remplacement ou c'est pas forcément le
but
comment tu vois ça eh bien oui figure
toi que j'ai fait une autre vidéo après
qui s'appelle on a fait ça paie jean
michel apathie ou en fait donc
jean-michel aphatie qu'un journaliste de
la radio des ondes publiques
je crois je sais pas très bien voilà
c'est un journaliste politique et donc
dans cette vidéo je propose une solution
alternative
enfin pour pour mémoriser la l'échelle
de moss et pour ça je me suis basé sur
des travaux du champion de la mémoire
qui s'appelle sébastien martinez enfin
un champion de la mémoire de ce qu'on a
chaque année je crois que tu as écrit un
bouquin et qui a fait une bd surtout
donc ça c'était plus à mon niveau sur
sur les différentes méthodes de
mémorisation pour se souvenir de ba de
phrases ou de séries de chiffres tout
comme ça et donc je me suis dit je vais
essayer d'appliquer ses méthodes à
l'échelle de moss for ce que ça va
donner
donc l'idée c'est de raconter une petite
histoire et de de susciter des émotions
des émotions fortes donc ça peut être
choqué ça peut être faire rire ça peut
être un truc complètement absurde
ça peut être un truc triste mais
l'important c'est que c'est comme ça
qu'on les mémorise et du coup je propose
une petite histoire
attention je n'ai noté parce que même
moi je m'en souviens pas donc en fait
pour le talk le premier donc je propose
d'un bébé qu'elle ait fait ce talk et
après le gypse donc le bébé valoir un
gipsy le gypsy est en calcif donc ça se
prend la calcite après ils vont voir ils
vont sur l'appli facebook ça c'est pour
la fluorite c'est un peu approximatif
mais j'avais très envie de parler de
faits de feuilles stop
après donc sur la petite faith ap ils
soumettent une image de jean michel
aphatie qui met avec le filtre audio
sauf qu'en fait c'est la même personne
donc là à pâtisser pour la patite après
on à leur cause et le quartz donc ça
c'est jean michel aphatie qui a une
orthèse à un bras et il est une montre à
quartz et après il ya adriana karembeu
qui arrivent et qui est topless c'est
pour le topaz et l'a donc le gypsy tombe
ah non je me suis trouvé ben riadh à 41
rives topless et elle est là pour faire
la quête pour la croix rouge et donc
elle dit aux gens encore a donc c'est
pour le corindon et le gypsy ton fou
amoureux d'elle et il lui offre un
diamant et voilà comment on arrive à
toutes les strates magnifique avec
plaisir à regarder cette vidéo
ok c'est un petit peu approximatif mais
l'idée c'est qu'on peut utiliser tous
les moyens de mots techniques
enfin combiné donc on peut très bien
gardé ta grosse concierge folle d'amour
utiliser ça en plus si on veut et l'idée
c'est de s'approprier les moyens
mnémotechniques donc on peut très bien
se fabriquer son son propre moyen de vos
techniques autour de l'échelle de moss
si on a vraiment rien d'autre à faire
c'est pourquoi pas
merci à toi